exploremos un poco más el círculo
unitario empecemos considerando un
ángulo teta y supongamos para fines de
este vídeo que todos los ángulos se
miden en radiales este ángulo que
tenemos aquí
llamémoslo teta y ahora reflejamos este
que podemos llamar el radio terminal del
ángulo vamos a reflejarlo a través del
eje xy del eje y pongamos las etiquetas
a los ejes empecemos con el reflejo a
través de la parte positiva del eje x
para esto bajamos una recta
perpendicular al eje x y encontramos el
punto de intersección con el círculo
unitario a la misma distancia obtenemos
así este rayo que estoy dibujando en
azul obtenemos este rayo que tenemos
aquí ahora cuál es el ángulo que se
forma entre el rayo y la parte positiva
del eje x empezando por la parte
positiva del eje x bien usando la
convención de que al girar a partir de
la parte positiva el eje x en sentido
contrario a las manecillas del reloj se
forma un ángulo positivo aquí el ángulo
es en sentido de las manecillas del
reloj en vez de ir hacia arriba va hacia
abajo así es que por la convención
ángulo de menos z ahora vamos a reflejar
este rayo original que tenemos en verde
a través de la parte positiva del eje y
así es que a partir de este punto
cruzamos la parte positiva del eje y de
manera perpendicular encontramos este
punto de intersección y a partir de ahí
vamos a construir este rayo aquí está lo
mejor que pude hacer este rayo y cuál
será la medida de este ángulo que
tenemos aquí cuál será la medida de ese
ángulo en radiales sabemos que si vamos
de la parte positiva del eje x a la
parte negativa del eje x el ángulo mide
y radiales
pues estamos recorriendo media
circunferencia ahora como este ángulo de
aquí sabemos que es igual al ángulo
original theta el ángulo que queremos
mide entonces piqué es la media vuelta
menos eta y menos teta y aquí podemos
checar que pi menos teta más te está
estos dos son ángulos suplementarios y
su suma nos da y menos teta teta es
igual a piedad yanes o 180 grados
vamos a reflejar este rayo a través de
la parte negativa del eje x encontramos
entonces el reflejo que sería este rayo
que tenemos aquí
este sería el reflejo y cuánto mide
entonces este ángulo todo este ángulo
cuánto mide bueno sabemos que la media
vuelta al círculo mide i y este pedazo
de aquí me de teta así es que el ángulo
completo mide y más z este ángulo este
ángulo de aquí que estoy marcando mide y
más teta déjame escribirlo aquí abajo
este ángulo mide y más teta radiales
ahora que ya hemos considerado estas
diversas simetrías del ángulo theta
veamos cómo se relacionan senos y
cosenos ya sabemos que las coordenadas
de este punto son seno de teta perdón la
coordenada en x es coseno de teta y la
coordenada en yes seno de teta otra
manera de ver esto es que este valor en
el eje x es coseno beteta mientras que
este valor en el eje y el seno de teta
ahora consideremos este punto aquí abajo
por la misma razón y estas son las
definiciones de las funciones
trigonométricas en el círculo unitario
en este punto dado que el ángulo es
menos theta las coordenadas son coseno
de - teta seno de menos teta seno de
menos teta y aquí aplicamos lo mismo la
coordenada de este punto es coseno del
ángulo y el ángulo aquí es pi - teta es
todo este ángulo que tenemos aquí coseno
de pi menos teta
seno
depp y menos theta seno de eta ahora
vayamos a este punto a este punto de acá
y creo que ya te estás dando cuenta a
dónde queremos llegar
las coordenadas son coseno de ti más te
está o te está más pi es lo mismo coseno
de pima z
seno
de ti más te está y cómo se relacionan
estas coordenadas entre sí observa que
aquí del lado derecho la coordenada en x
es la misma es este valor que tenemos
aquí por lo cual entonces coseno de teta
es igual a coseno de - zeta vamos a
escribir aquí este resultado coseno de
teta es igual es igual a oa poner con
este azul es igual a coseno de menos
teta y este resultado es realmente
interesante qué pasa con el seno vemos
que aquí se no detecta corresponde a
este valor en y qué pasa con 0 - teta
corresponde al mismo valor de ye pero
con el signo contrario los valores son
iguales pero de signo opuesto el
resultado que obtenemos por esto es que
el seno de menos teta
es igual
- el seno de teta menos el seno de teta
si te mueves hacia arriba o hacia abajo
del eje x vas a obtener el valor
contrario para el seno veamos ahora
estos dos puntos
cómo se relaciona bien podemos ver que
el pse no es igual el seno de pi menos
teta es igual al seno de teta escribamos
lo por aquí el seno de teta es igual a
el seno
de vie - teta y qué pasa con los cosenos
vemos que los cosenos son opuestos los
valores que tienen las coordenadas en x
son iguales pero se encuentran en
direcciones opuestas con respecto al
origen por lo que ccoo seno de teta es
igual a menos coseno de aquí ya mezcle
colores no déjame ponerlo mejor con el
color adecuado
coseno de teta es igual a menos coseno
depp y menos teta
finalmente veamos cómo se relaciona esté
aquí el coseno la coordenada en x es
negativa y el seno también es negativo
hemos reflejado ambas coordenadas a
través del origen escribamos eso acá
el xenón
seno de eta más pique lo mismo que el
seno de eta esto es igual
- seno de teta este s 9 teta este es
menos seno de eta que es el seno desde
está más pío pimas teta y el co seno de
eta más pi es igual el coche no detecta
más p es igual a menos el coche no de
teta menos el coche no de teta y así
podríamos continuar relacionando este
con este oeste con este de acá y seguir
obteniendo resultados así de
interesantes
te invito a que te tomes un tiempo y lo
pruebes por tu cuenta y veas como todos
estos se pueden relacionar basados en la
simetría y las reflexiones que se dan a
través de los ejes x sigue